[MUSIC PLAYING]
JESSICA HARROP: Hi, I'm
Jessica and today I'm
going to talk to you about a
chemical demonstration I like
to call colorful indicators.
Indicators show us
what we normally
wouldn't be able to see, from
the canary in the coal mine
to a paint that changes
color with temperature
to the acid base indicators
we'll be seeing today.
And chemist Dr. Bassam
Shakhashiri here he is--
is going to be
showing us the demo.
He's the president of the
American Chemical Society
and performing this
demo right here at MIT.
[WHOOSH]
BASSAM SHAKHASHIRI: Now
what I'm going to do
is an experiment using another
form of carbon dioxide.
It's called dry ice.
Dry ice is solid carbon dioxide.
And you'll notice
I'm putting what on?
AUDIENCE: Gloves.
BASSAM SHAKHASHIRI:
Putting gloves.
And I'm going to
open this bucket
and pick up three chunks
of carbon dioxide solid.
This is solid carbon dioxide.
Its temperature is minus
78 degrees Celsius.
It's very cold.
Dry ice changes from being a
solid to a gas by a process we
call sublimation.
Sublimation is happening right
now, but we can't see it.
How come we can't see it?
Because carbon dioxide
as gas is what?
AUDIENCE: Invisible.
BASSAM SHAKHASHIRI:
It's invisible.
It has no color.
So sublimation is
happening right now.
We can't see it.
And I'm going to put
those three back in here
and ask you to focus your
attention on what you
see between my two hands here.
What do you see
between my two hands?
In order to sharpen your
powers of observation
and develop the skills of
reporting these observations,
I ask you to pretend to be the
play by play radio announcer,
describing to someone who was
not with us what's going on.
Not the TV announcer,
that person
has got it made because
the picture tells
almost everything.
So, there are how
many cylinders?
AUDIENCE: Six.
BASSAM SHAKHASHIRI: And what do
you see inside the cylinders?
AUDIENCE: Colored liquid.
BASSAM SHAKHASHIRI:
Colored liquids.
OK, I'm listening
to you on the radio.
And what I hear you say is
that there are six cylinders.
And they have in
them colored liquids.
Come on.
Your brain learned a
lot more information
than those two
statements, right?
Right?
So they're about
this big, you said.
I can see you on the radio
saying it's about this big,
right?
You've got to do
better than this, OK?
Are they 100
milliliters in size?
Are they 10 milliliters in size?
Are they somewhere in between?
Yes.
We put a bracket on it when
we estimate in science.
We put a bracket on it.
All right.
And they have, yes,
colored liquids.
How do you know they're liquids?
They could be gels.
How do we find out?
We shake them up a little bit.
Because we know from
experience, it's a keyword,
we learn things-- a brain learns
things, so we use them, right?
So they're liquids.
So I'm going to take
chunks of dry ice
and put them in the cylinders
in a very special way.
And when I get done, you tell
me what the special way is.
AUDIENCE: It's blowing out.
BASSAM SHAKHASHIRI:
What's blowing out?
You see any bubbles?
What kind of bubbles are those?
AUDIENCE: Blue.
Green.
BASSAM SHAKHASHIRI: What?
You want to know
what's in there?
You already know
what's in there.
Dry ice, I put the
dry ice in there.
What did I put the dry ice into?
Into two cylinders that have
colored liquids in them, right?
And I put the dry ice
in every other cylinder.
I didn't put it in
every cylinder, right?
Every other cylinder, leaving
one for comparison purposes.
So these are dyes that change
color when the pH of the liquid
changes.
[WHOOSH]
JESSICA HARROP: All right.
So let's break down.
What's happening
in these cylinders.
There's six of them.
And each set is
a different color
because they're different acid
base indicators inside them.
So this set starts out blue.
This one starts out pink.
And the final one is purple.
And every cylinder contains a
few drops of sodium hydroxide,
which is a base.
NaOH, sodium hydroxide,
and it's a base.
So let's start with the basics.
What is an acid and a base?
One definition is that
acids are compounds
that donate a hydrogen ion or
H plus to another compound.
And the compound that accepts
that hydrogen ion is a base.
So acids are
hydrogen ion donors.
And bases are hydrogen
ion acceptors.
Here's some examples.
Sodium hydroxide is a base.
It's used to make soap.
And acetic acid,
which looks like this,
it makes vinegar sour.
All right, so let's look
back at our cylinders here.
This first set of cylinders
contains the indicator
bromothymol blue.
Let's take a look
at the spectrum.
All right, so let's take a
look at bromothymol blue,
the indicator in the
first set of cylinders.
As you can see here,
there's a scale of numbers.
This is a pH scale.
The higher the number, the
more basic the solution.
The lower the number,
the more acidic.
So our solution
started off basic.
It was blue.
It had sodium hydroxide in it.
And this is what the chemical
structure of the molecule
looks like when it's blue.
The chemical bonds
in the molecule
are absorbing colors of
the visible spectrum that
are not blue.
So blue is reflected
back to our eyes.
Now, if our compound picks
up a hydrogen ion which
it would if you added an acid to
it, the molecule changes color.
Now it absorbs blue
and reflects yellow.
Since the colors depend on
the structure of the molecule,
a chemist could
reprogram the molecule
to switch its
color at other pHs,
other numbers on this scale.
That's useful depending
on the kind of reactions
she may want to study.
Now, nature experiments
with color all the time.
Animals use color to avoid
predators, attract mates,
scare off enemies, etc.
[WHOOSH]
All right, so now
let's take a look
at what's happening in the
second set of cylinders
that started off pink.
[WHOOSH]
The indicator in there
is phenolphthalein.
The same thing is happening
with our bromothymol blue,
but this time when the
solution is basic, it's pink.
And when it's acidic,
it's colorless.
[WHOOSH]
But why does adding dry
ice change the solution
from basic to acidic?
Well, dry ice is
solid carbon dioxide.
When you add it to
water, it bubbles.
And part of every bubble of
carbon dioxide dissolves.
When it does, it
forms carbonic acid.
Let's look at that equation.
So there's more and more
carbonic acid in the water.
And this acid reacts
with the sodium hydroxide
until there's none left.
So the solution becomes acidic.
So we saw our bromothymol blue
turning from blue to yellow
as the solution
became more acidic.
And we saw our phenolphthalein
turn from pink to colorless
as it became more acidic.
Now, let's watch
again what happens
in the final set of cylinders.
[WHOOSH]
BASSAM SHAKHASHIRI: All right.
So now I ask you to focus your
attention on this cylinder.
Actually, you can
focus your attention
on anything you want to, OK?
You can even not pay
attention if you want to.
We live in a free country.
But if you want to follow
the experiment with me,
I want you to focus your
attention on this one
and tell me, count them out,
how many different color
changes you see as I drop
the dry ice in there.
I'm listening to
you on the radio.
One.
Wow, I heard wow.
What kind of a count is that?
Three so far.
Three different color changes.
But you know, I'm listening
to you on the radio.
You want me to appreciate
what you're seeing,
so what were the color
changes that you saw?
Why couldn't you
say those, right?
You see how we have
to help our brain make
the right observations and
make the right reporting.
[WHOOSH]
JESSICA HARROP: OK, so in
the final set of cylinders,
Dr. Shakhashiri has a
mixture of indicators.
This created the
color changes that
occurred as the solution
became more and more acidic.
There were three
changes that we saw.
It went from purple to
blue to green to yellow.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
All right, that's
it for me today.
I'll see you next time.